i'm wondering if you can recount your
story about sneaking into shows
in detroit going over the was it the
canadian border yep
i grew up in windsor ontario canada so
there's uh
there's a river that separates the two
countries i
take the bridge of the tunnel and you
know literally it's a couple of minutes
you cross the border and
you're in detroit which was always great
because we just had so much access to
entertainment that this small city in
canada didn't have you know
you could go see a red wings game go see
lions game see the tigers play
or all of the big concerts from michael
jackson right on down would would come
there
uh and i just had this idea i was i was
broke but
you know i had a video camera i wanted
to like meet people and and really i
only did it because i wanted to meet the
band so i just you know sort of made
some fake
press credentials uh for canadian media
tv station i won't mention uh now
now defunct so it wouldn't matter but i
was able to
get in on on the premise of like hey i'm
supposed to be here to interview the
band and
uh you know take this video clip back to
the news station oh
you're not on the list oh gee i'm gonna
get fired if i don't
i don't have this and nine out of ten
times it would work
and most of the time that led to them
saying like well do you need a pass to
film some of the show as well
so i i did it as a way one just to meet
bands that i liked that was the bonus or
at least get a pass to see the show that
i didn't have to pay for
because i love going to music venues but
you know as a broke
you know 20 something filmmaker i didn't
have the money to go see all these shows
uh and then one of those bands that i
that i originally did that was the rock
band third eye blind
uh and ended up befriending steven their
singer and the other guys in the band
and actually got hired to create content
for the band and stayed in touch and
steven
at the time around the time was
producing a record for
the artist vanessa carlton she had the
song a thousand miles that was used in
most people know from white chicks they
sing it in the car
uh you know beautiful huge super hit
song and
they needed somebody to shoot the making
of her second album
so that was my first trip out to
hollywood uh shot this documentary got
to edit it all together
uh that was sold as like a double thing
like it came as a bonus dvd
with her with her album and uh
you know had i not snuck into that
concert once
wouldn't have had my first la trip
wouldn't have had my first sort of
professional paycheck doing anything in
the film industry
and it started to open up opportunities
for bands saying like well
if you do all this behind the scenes and
tour video stuff like could you shoot a
music video
and just never say no just say yes and
then figure it out
uh so that that led to you know my first
music videos which was
a hundred and something music videos ago
so it's the best uh
rule breaking i've ever done you know i
love third eye blind so it's a very cool
band to get your start with
do you remember the first time they said
yes and you got to go in like the green
room or wherever it was and what was
that like
as this 20 something year old uh well it
was right there that that first night
because i was going to interview steven
uh that that was part of it and uh ended
up
right as the interview ended talking to
their bass player and i was a big fan of
the band they they had three albums out
at the time the third album had just
come out
and uh and got chatting with him and he
had he had acted in the matrix the
second matrix movie
so he was telling me all about that set
experience was just the nicest guy ever
and i had just
shot my first indie feature film
uh and we were talking about he said oh
i've always wanted to compose music for
films and everything so that
i could do your movie i was like this
would be amazing so we created emails
there so like
i kind of had it was just honestly it
couldn't have gone any better
if i tried um but at the same time i
didn't
hang around any longer than i needed to
be there
um you know that's one thing as as a fan
or or in any industry party or events
like you know no
no you know your place and don't
overstep your bounds or
people's comfort zones sure sometimes
you're on the list and they won't
they don't believe you that you're that
that happens more often than not
yeah no i'm supposed to be here i swear
did i understand it correctly that used
to rent video cameras in the beginning
way back yeah i was uh we're talking
like vhs cameras so we
i think the first time my family did it
was on a family trip to disney world in
the late 80s or early 90s we just
rented one so that you could you could
rent it and film your adventure in the
park and then just you know keep keep
the tape that you filmed on
and uh that was probably my first
directing experience
because that my mom still has the tape
somewhere and most of it is just me
bossing my younger brother around
like no i'm going to turn the camera on
i'm going to say action and then you
walk over here and i'm going to be
pointing at the top of the the
castle and pan down and you'll walk in
and wave and like so
i had no idea what directing was but
apparently that's that's what i was
doing
and then when i had a paper route
growing up around the same time or maybe
a year or two later
my friend troy schwager and i and my
neighbor eli parent
were sort of obsessed with making movies
so the local video shop rented the you
know he'd rent the camcorder for
20 or 30 bucks for the weekend so we
would get all the neighborhood kids
together and our younger siblings and
make
indiana jones the lost controller you
know looking for the remotes or
mostly just parody videos friday the
13th
part 26 or whatever fun home alone three
just you know building our own traps in
the houses and mostly to
also just injure our younger brothers
and so it's like half jackass and half
parody films
but yeah we that it would that's uh but
the only way to edit then
for us was to shoot a shot press pause
and then get ready to shoot the next one
and record so that we just had to sort
of edit in camera
and shoot everything in sequence which
was an amazing skill set to learn that i
didn't realize i was learning of how to
like
minimize the number of setups and shots
and only shoot exactly what you need to
make a movie
so it's definitely helped save money
even even to this day on music video
shoots
was your plan to stay in ontario or did
you want to go to la or that was never
in the cards
i definitely wanted to go to la to go to
film school but as an
international student everything is is
far more expensive
uh the exchange rate rarely works in the
uh
canadian dollar's favor so it was just
gonna be way too expensive and when i
left high school
i went to work at a walmart and said
okay i'm gonna
i'm gonna save up money i'll work here
for a year or two and then go to film
school
i had looked in toronto with ryerson but
you know like you see
reading about spielberg and everybody
else like ucla was
the place and uh i ended up
injuring myself with a hernia working
managing the garden center at walmart
in windsor and wasn't able to work at
all
and that's when i said you know what i
bet yeah i could i used to do like the
video
yearbook or sort of like similar kind of
videos
for the school and make a little bit of
money selling copies at the end of the
year i thought
maybe i could like do wedding videos or
some local tv commercials
and that's when i started a business of
my own and that's the last
walmart's the last job job that i had
when i was about 18 or 19 and i've just
always done something video related
since since then so yeah it wasn't
really until
i i met my wife we got married and she's
an actress and she wanted to
give la a try we came out here for the
premiere of one of our films and she
just tried surfing and just
instantly fell in love with it and said
we need to be here whatever it takes
what's the easiest year you've had
filmmaking we're just everything sort of
just like there were green lights
everywhere
oh man is that a thing
uh i would say 2012
i was doing a lot of independent music
videos i did a lot of them that year i
did like 30
35 or 40 music videos in one year so it
was almost week after week like
uh i hadn't learned the art of saying no
yet because it just always feels when
you're independent that like if you
don't say yes to something you're never
going to get
the next project from that band or that
record label
and so i would you know pitch a music
video
and then the next day shoot something
and then that would get green lit and
then while i was editing something we'd
shoot some so there's always like
one in preparation one shooting one in
post and i do all of my own editing as
well so it's just
the the year just blew by and had done
so much stuff
in so many different formats you know
single take music videos
a rap video an independent video a video
with a bigger budget
it was just the best way to sort of
train myself to work
efficiently use the money why you know
because the
music video but just keep dropping and
dropping and a lot of them were just
sort of friends bands or people starting
out so there wasn't a budget so it was
the best sort of year of
building a toolkit of skills that i
could use moving forward for
micro budget features that i wanted to
make uh and i was traveling a lot
from windsor to toronto's like the the
closest major canadian city with an
industry
and uh i just spent a lot of time in
toronto and had a lot of hype around the
feature script that i had called four
shots at the time that we were in
development on so it was just
sort of the perfect year where really
thought oh man it's going to stay like
this forever
and then of course it changes
well my next question was uh or is uh
what was the worst year
and do you think anything it was just a
matter of luck
for both situations it would be
i'm trying to think when things i
remember the years exactly probably 2013
the end of 2012
so the script i had four shots had been
greenlit
multiple times had the budget raised
multiple times it fell apart and that
stuff is standard it happens in
filmmaking all the time but
this particular script was about a
shooting in a high school kind of a
columbine story
but told in a really interesting way it
was going to be told in a single take
so the camera showed it never shuts off
it was multi-screen so it was showing
what it would be like but for different
students perspectives to be trapped
inside the school
and when we wrote it like nothing had
been done you know there had been the
blair witch project
but there wasn't a paranormal activity
yet there wasn't a cloverfield there
wasn't a chronicle there wasn't
everything else that came with the
camcorder and started the found footage
craze
so we really kind of had like that
lightning in a bottle thing but because
of the
the politics and the sensitivity of the
subject matter
every time there would be you know and
from columbine
until virginia tech there was not really
a sort of mass shooting or especially in
a school setting
uh so we we first got the script off the
ground right
before like literally a month or two
before virginia tech happened and then
everybody
pulled out of that we had set it up
again with a with icon
films and d films and canada and were in
development for for a long time
and uh and then there was the batman
movie theater shooting in colorado and
aurora
that lost losses our investors and you
know and it even makes us
the filmmakers squeamish too of like uh
i know i know we're not
i know the script does not
sensationalize the subject matter
but it still makes you you know when
things like that are happening in real
life it makes it hard to
to want to be creative and tell a
fictional story about it
uh and then that same year was the sandy
hook elementary shooting
and we were actually sort of getting
into rehearsals and we were fully cast
and ready to go
and uh and that happened and that it
fell apart again so for me it had been
five years of chasing the same project
not making a movie at all
um nothing else was like working out i
wanted to move to toronto but
i've been staying in windsor because we
were going to make the movie in windsor
and it just made more sense we had a
high school that was willing to donate
the entire building
that we could make this happen you know
on a small budget
so it was it was a really tough year to
put in five years working it really we
were right there and we had all the
major players then it went away and then
you have the thought of like will i
will i ever get another film made that
was happening the same year 2012 so 2013
the
first half of the year was a real dark
place of like did i just waste
five years of my life and it had been
affecting personal relationships and
things like that as well because
i was just so you kind of have to be a
little
completely laser focused on getting any
movie made
and we were just so focused on making
that happen that it just
it caused strife in just about every
other department
and what did they what what did various
parties tell you if you could
you know just maybe scroll it down when
they would pass let's suppose you were
ready to do something and then
it was less passive it's just a concern
you know um
what what's the recourse of this film
going to be well will we get sued
like what's the what's the public outcry
going to be and
in a way they're a little predictive of
what sort of like the backlash society
we've seen in the last few years or the
minute
you know peop people trip up and make a
mistake in phrasing something wrong on
the internet and the public
outcry is so huge that they were
probably right that i was
you know one of the one of the plans was
to always have me do pr training
before i did any interviews for the
movie because like if you say
anything that sounds remotely
insensitive or
or you know like make you know making
light of the the topic of mass shootings
and
you know like teenagers dying in high
school like we we might have a pr
nightmare you know
um so they were they were very i think
you know
in some ways they were there were
profits that they knew and you know
sometimes these companies are
public traded companies and they just
you know they they have to
derive away from all potential
controversies or
and we've seen in the past you know mel
gibson couldn't get uh
passion of the christ financed or
finished with miramax at the time you
know they were owned by disney and
um but before their you know their
current
current issues but they
you know so when icon got on board we
thought oh we have a company that
understands controversy and
uh it just yeah it just kept getting too
sensitive and
and delayed the project and then at that
point i just had to walk away and say i
need to go make a different movie and
not
not keep having this same because who
knows you know the
public shootings and it might have been
the right move because public students
have not
stopped um you know some of them have
been
more horrific than than anything else in
history
and uh although i don't believe we
shouldn't not tell stories about things
that are happening i definitely
understand why people
got a little sensitive about it have you
thought of rewriting the script or
adding a new
part of it in order to
not satisfy anybody who might be too
sensitive but
take a new spin with it yeah it would
just be a completely different movie at
that point i think
part of what i love about it uh and one
of the things i like to ingest in a lot
of my filmmaking is just something
that's very raw
and feels real and this this definitely
was part of
the issue too was to make a movie like a
blair witch like part of it is
it's like being able to market it and
and sort of fool the public and say like
did this or did this not really happen
and that's where a lot of the
sensitivity came from like
in order to make the movie successful
that's how we have to market it but then
that's the thing that could have the
biggest backlash
i it's my favorite script and at some
point in time if i have the money to
just go out and make it i'll
self-finance it
and you know it's it's um
but i ended up getting to make last call
which is is a similar idea of doing the
split screen
and single take so uh i've
satisfied and i did a project for
blumhouse we did the world's first live
movie that kind of had a bit of the
the same goal so i've sort of taken that
that energy and storytelling that i
wanted to do with four shots and put it
into other projects that were less less
controversial
one last question about it and then
we'll move on but um was the truther
movement
uh very strong at that time you know how
there's the full movement of like a lot
of this is staged and for very good
yeah was it was it strong at that time
no no no i think
when saying you know especially the
sandy hook one that's the one that that
has the most
you know alex jones notoriously has had
a huge outcry to say that this never
happened but
that wasn't i mean conspiracy theories
pop up about everything but but it
wasn't
i don't think it was anywhere near as
rampant and we were talking like the
direct
aftermath you know and then the real
truth is you know like somebody
somebody pointed a gun at at children
like little kids
not the teenagers are any better or
college kids or people in a bank or
anywhere else but it was
it was just a different kind of
disturbing
that it could really happen anywhere and
i i don't think even us
as the filmmakers and the producers
really wanted to
make it it's just something that turns
your stomach enough to not
not care to pursue it anymore
at this stage in your career how do you
measure your success
i'm working and i get to wake up every
day and make
make movies and music videos i uh you
know i've come close to a few
bigger sort of studio deals and projects
uh
even my the film previously that's the
scarehouse you know was picked up by
universal studios and released
between them and a company called d film
sort of like packaged and put out all
over the world and
still on cable and that was wonderful
but it takes so much
time and energy and patience to go
through the studio system
that i've sort of carved out that
although that's still a dream and i'd
love to direct tv and there's lots of
things i haven't done
i'm also very comfortable with making my
own films and finding smaller amounts of
financing and using all
the skills i've developed through making
no budget music videos and short films
with friends to just sort of
always have something in the works that
is is creative and different that
you know if i tried to make last call
this weird split screen movie with no
stars like
what do you mean we can't edit it or
change it if we don't like it and post
like i don't know
how far that would have got through the
studio system being somebody without a
lot of clout or a track record of any
any kind of material the same
so for me it's it's waking up knowing
that the film the weird little indie
films i want to make
that my passion can be a reality and i
can get to make those
and and if i could do that till the day
i die i'd be i'd be thrilled
and with that sort of mindset anything
larger or bigger opportunities that
could pop up
are are really just just a dream they'd
be
they'd be wonderful but they're not
necessary for me to feel satisfied
as a storyteller i'm just as happy
making a film with my iphone or my sony
a7s with some friends for a weekend
as you know having proper financing and
a full crew and running around so i
think that that was the big thing to
come to that like
being a filmmaker doesn't mean the house
in the hills it doesn't mean
you know being on entertainment tonight
it doesn't mean opening globally and box
office numbers it's about
finding the stories and then the things
that you want to say
and then finding sort of your voice or a
unique way to say them
do you think a studio would touch the
topic the the subject matter of last
call i mean it's beautifully shot
and and you have a live score right that
that goes back to
two screens but do you think they would
touch the subject matter
i think i think there's been a lot of uh
you know the film deals with suicide
it's a mental health story for sure um
it's it's a little dark i don't want to
give anything away it's it's
a little darker than maybe uh
i think there's a lot of you know a star
is born just i had a massive i don't
give away spoilers but there's a big
there's a big mental health component to
that
uh 13 reasons why opens you know the
netflix series always based on a book
but it opens on
a teenage girl who's committed suicide
and left these tapes behind
the 13 reasons why i you know what led
to this decision so that's
that's dark and there was a lot of
people that were upset about it and i
remember reading some sort of petitions
and parents groups that were not happy
with it
you know living in fear that it would
you know cause their
their teenage impressionable children to
to take the same path and i think that's
the wrong way to approach it
the approach would be let's sit down and
discuss this and and how to avoid this
and learn from it
um so i i think there's
and i don't i can't remember in recent
times like recent years before that
anything that was tackling the same but
i also feel like we're in a stage where
just as a society we're only really
starting to understand
mental illness and mental health and
medicating for it you know and i'm far
from an expert
i'll never claim that last call uh
has has a firm stance on this is the way
it is and this is the way that it
happens
we made a movie for entertainment
purposes but we did our very best to
research the content and try to make it
feel as real
to to a real life situation but i think
i think we do live in a time where as a
society and especially with social media
to keep things in check
you know instantly if people are liking
the content you're creating or not
and uh there's a lot of great cinema
that brings up brings up topical things
you know i think of movies like
um tangerine that was shot on the iphone
and
and deals deals with the lgbt community
and things that in a way that we had
never seen like just just the fact that
i think what's happening too is because
anyone can make a movie now
people that wouldn't have been able to
tell these weird quirky stories about
different different groups or topics
that aren't
widely covered by hollywood i mean most
people want to go to the movies if
you're paying them to go to the movies
and take your family you want to watch a
star wars you want to watch a marvel
movie you want to watch toy story you
know what i mean
you got to be entertained and life is
life and politics and
finances and everything else are already
like so heavy in so many people's lives
like you
you want to go to be uplifted but for
the rest of us that just like gripping
stories and want to learn more about
different pockets of the world
uh it's it's a fantastic revolution but
i think that's where you'll always see
topics that aren't given enough
spotlight is is going to come up through
independent cinema
until it almost becomes sort of like
accepted or or embraced and then the
studio systems will will
often catch on and and make content the
same thing
what prompted you to co-write the film
david
wilkins that i wrote it with it's his
idea he came to me
he ran a weekly coffee get together
which uh essentially it's uh actors
filmmakers it's just a group of us
and he invited me to that once i met him
and the idea is you can't talk about
anything negative you can only talk
about the pod you can have coffee
and you can talk positive you can't
complain about your agent you can't
complain about how you didn't book that
role you can't complain about
uh you know getting rejected for a
screenplay you wrote you just have to
talk about positive things and it's a
way to encourage people to like
look at life and this career which is
difficult
uh through a new light and then also try
to network people
and he just came in one day says i have
this idea it'd be like a great acting
piece like maybe it's a short film like
maybe it's a guy but it's a guy calling
a suicide hotline
you like doing real time he had acted in
the single take music video i did
he had seen a 20-minute short film that
the cinematographer of last call and i
had done about a year before
said i think you could do this in real
time um
and originally it was him the character
calling a suicide hotline what it
evolved into
was uh the character of scott calling
and misdialing and getting connected to
a random stranger
because we thought that added a lot more
dynamic if the person on the other side
of the phone didn't
didn't have the the knowledge or the or
the education
or the skill set necessarily to handle
somebody who's suicidal on the other
line so there are there are some ups and
downs
in the story of last call that come from
somebody's unpreparedness and
sort of almost like unprofessionalism
and their approach to dealing with him
but
it was just it's i always say it's like
one of those lightning bolt moments
where he started talking about it as
like
real time and then we can show both
sides of the story
maybe we could actually shoot it
simultaneously at two different parts of
the city
this is like what i wanted to do with my
school shooting movie which of course
that was all contained in one building
and a little easier but
uh just on the technical challenge and
the story challenge that that was just
it
david and i have been talking about
finding something to work on together
for a while
uh so this was our first foray into it
but just not that anything's easy to
write ever but we were just able to like
every idea
he had he'd say i'd say well what about
this and it got a little better and
you know he texts me in the middle of
the night i was thinking about this
scene what do you think and just
everything was kind of like
better better better better we're like
okay we we obviously can work well
together let's uh
let's see if we can make this but we
went from idea to sort of shooting the
movie in about a year span
maybe a little longer and it probably
would have happened faster but we uh
i i was always busy he booked a
commercial like
sarah who accident would book a tv
series so we were always kind of uh
the only thing there were no obstacles
really in making getting this movie to
camera other than the fact that we were
all busy
filming other projects can you talk
about the screenwriting process so david
had this idea
yeah and you two were bouncing ideas off
of each other but
how did the actual screenplay process
work out david and i would try to get
together in person as often as possible
i'm a stickler for outlining the story
before you start writing
writing dialogue so a lot of it was just
the painstaking and this this because we
have two sides of the story we have to
make sure that there's something
interesting happening
on both sides of the screen at the same
time and
um you know it's interesting because for
an audience perspective they can see
say for example there's a moment it's
not a big spoiler but like scott lies
and says that he's stopped drinking he
isn't gonna have anything else to drink
so she feels relieved and the things are
going the right way but what the
audience can see is that's not the case
so we're sort of always ahead of the
game we want to sort of give it that
perspective
but also finding ways where just the the
synergy of
if she's sitting in the darkness or
talking about a dark story then
he's out on the balcony in the light
just ways to keep a story interesting
that would translate visually when
you're never cutting and can't go back
and cut anything
because real time that's that's it you
know you're done we have no hidden cuts
there's
there's nothing like that so a lot of it
was just figuring out the structure of
how to do the story but also having a
story where
we're going to have one phone call for
the entire time the dynamics of that
the reveals of informations the sort of
like twists or shocks or turns
just just pasting that out was the
agonizing part
and then you know dave and i both really
enjoy writing dialogue
and david i think some of the most
beautiful dialogue he's he's written to
date out of anything i've read
is in this script um you know a lot of
that was he
he was always going to play scott in the
movie you know he's the actor in the
film as well
so i think he was able to also cater
writing that would
suit his skill set and uh and really
help
draw the best of his acting talents and
and the character
and then once we knew that uh sarah
booth was going to play
beth i also you know i've had a great
chance to work with her a handful of
times i've seen her on stage and one-act
plays that are
you know two hours on stage with no seam
brakes i just knew that we could also
throw
a lot of you know heavy dialogue at her
that she'd be able to do it and
yeah we try to meet as much as possible
we use the software writer's duet
to write the script writers who operates
similar to google docs where if you have
multiple people on it
even if we're not together we can see
every change word by word just appears
in the document
so if i'm sitting looking at the screen
and david's writing i can see what's
being changed
as you know even if we're working
remotely and then what was neat was
we were able to since it was david and
sarah and we're all friends and
or lived you know sarah's my wife so we
live together it's easy to schedule
rehearsal times we would actually get
together
read through portions of the script
we're able to sort of like adapt based
on hearing it out loud
and then leading up to the actual we
were writing the film right into the
film production because there's also
we always knew there'd be what we call
like an accordion effect
where until we could actually rehearse
it
on set and like okay well it says that
scott walks from the bar
to his apartment is that going to be
seven minutes long is that going to be
12 minutes long is that three minutes
long based on the locations we had we
knew that we probably have to
add or remove dialogue to get it in the
sort of time frame that we wanted the
finished film to be
so every day that we would rehearse
things we would change things remove
things
add more and we were able to sort of
film every rehearsal and see how it
so sort of a living breathing script
right up until
even the first couple takes versus the
last takes there are changes to the
to the story and the characters that
happen so it was a little different than
anything
else we'd written but what ended up
being really neat was sarah had gone to
montreal to shoot a project david was in
la
and i was in windsor prepping things for
the movie
and working on a couple music videos in
ontario so we would do
our rehearsals over the phone so them as
actors were already doing what they were
going to have to do on screen
and i was able to just kind of listen to
the phone call
as the director and one of the writers
and make notes and say
this is boring this doesn't work this
this is this is mumbling and confusing
and not clear
so sort of that that busyness benefited
the script being able to sort of
rehearse it the way it was going to be
performed
and you shot the film in canada you said
shot the film my home city in windsor
ontario canada so anybody who's seen the
film or has a chance
the bridge in the background it is not
uh brooklyn or new york it is it is
detroit
michigan it's the ambassador bridge that
connects the countries
my you know we were we our goal with
this film was to make it
super micro budget so that we wouldn't
be out of pocket
we also know making independent film
like the landscapes changing
there's no more blockbuster there's
barely a dvd in home video market
anymore
so you have to make your movies that
don't have big stars in them
you have to make them for a fraction of
the budget if you want to
be successful at recouping money at the
end of the day
so having said all that shooting at home
i knew you know the college we worked at
a deal with the college that we filmed
in because in the script
the character of beth is the night
janitor at a college but we had this
beautiful college building that we had
full access to
every day to rehearse and light and prep
and shoot the movie in
and they essentially sponsored the movie
and
even had some of their students come out
help on set and help behind the scenes
which was phenomenal
uh the film score was recorded live in a
single take and that was done at the
college's
beautiful theater the chrysler theater
in windsor again they they helped us we
we did that event as a student event
where high school students could come
and watch the making of
of a score and learn about how film
music is created so
my home city is always not a lot of
filmmaking happens there
so it's exciting we always try to
involve the students and the people we
had restaurants local restaurants that
sponsored us
and hotels that cut us deals for the out
of town cast and crew so the
the limited funds we did have we could
put on the screen and
in the production value and not uh don't
worry about if
if we shot it in la i think the price
would honestly be quadrupled
with the permits and and you know if if
i needed to close entire streets to walk
from a bar to an apartment building it
just
i don't think it would have happened um
you know we had this high rise up but
it's just everything worked out perfect
the bar we filmed in is my favorite bar
back home vermouth
uh my friend matt that owns the bar is
also an actor so he plays the bartender
and the bar owner in the movie
there was just so much sort of perfect
synergy to shoot it there that
i can't imagine us having done it at one
point i tossed her for about five and a
half seconds i said
what if we shot one side in la and one
side in windsor
and then we truly have this phone call
that's across you know
even the border and uh and everybody
said no that's true
we don't have maybe one day when we have
the money we'll do something bigger
yeah what were some of the questions
that the high school students asked and
were
you also so surprised at how advanced
they were um uh
well there wasn't a whole lot of time
for questions a lot
a lot of it was uh based around where
where's sort of the emotion
where does the composer uh you know our
composer adrian ellis where does he
start
like how do you look at something with
no music and say
how do you choose what instrument how do
you choose like
are you telling the action of the story
versus the k is it is the music themed
around the characters
um i think film music has
an amazing appreciation so you know a
lot of them would we ask some
we ask questions like what's your
favorite film scores and like you know
inception
star wars uh edward scissorhands you
know that all the big composers come out
so
i feel they were we had some music
classes as well so they had some very
specific things to ask of our string
quartet
and and how the and then people that are
just interested in filmmaking
understanding so it's recorded here but
then how does it actually get mixed into
the movie and
uh and this one was a little different
too because adrian and i we
you know you typically music fades out
as the scene ends
and then it cuts to a new scene and a
different music cue comes in or it
doesn't
with this there's no starting stops to
scenes being in the single takes we we
had a
real trouble figuring out okay we want
to have music coming in emotionally but
it's going to be it can't feel cheap or
forced or just suddenly like
and now there's dramatic music because
there wasn't an organic way to sort of
bring it in
uh so we we had not not fights but a lot
a lot of head scratching on that one of
what to
what to do we always knew we wanted to
do the music live but
uh it was everything on this film was a
different process so
i should have figured when we got to
music it would be it was going to be a
challenge
and last call has distribution nope we
made the film our intention was
i founded a distribution company and we
said if all else fails we will
self-distribute
i've been through the distribution
ringer a few different times where i've
never seen the profit participation i'm
supposed to
it is not uncommon in this business
unfortunately the music in the film
industry have this very crooked
reputation
and it's for a reason it is crooked it
should it deserves a terrible reputation
uh so if we are not able to secure a
reputable distributor that also
will get the film to the masses and cut
us a fair deal
with proper profit participation we said
we this is a small enough amount of
money that i feel confident
and taking it out ourselves and
we have some sort of inventive ways that
i haven't seen before to release indie
film
i'm no stranger for marketing and trying
to sell out screenings in different
cities
had success with that so we thought we
could definitely do it on our own so
that was part of the
the fun of this movie having the freedom
to know that we didn't have to shoot
something that would
please distributors or again because a
lot of times an indie film gets made
you find a proper distributor and they
say okay we want to change this this
maybe change this it's like well we
can't we
we can't edit anything in this movie the
most you could do is adjust the music or
or the color correction but other than
that it is what it is so we knew
we'd be up against maybe not even being
able to find a traditional distributor
and when you make something experimental
you just you never know what you
honestly even as the director you go
this is what we hope for
we don't know how it's going to turn out
or how audiences will receive it
so we said let's just make something
that we're comfortable releasing
ourselves and we know that that's
that's a plan that we're all happy with
would be thrilled with
and that way anything else that comes
along really is a dream come true
are you able to divulge some of how you
found the distribution company or what
some of your plans are or
some of that's like under wraps it's um
yeah
that's all still very initial it's
called uh
fu entertainment which is
an acronym for uh filmmakers unite
because nobody else will stand up for us
then we should just say fu to the
entertainment industry
uh just a little tongue-in-cheek stab at
things
uh but i do you know i have a lot of
director and producer friends and that
make these great indie movies and sort
of all get stuck
in the same the same system don't earn
their money back like some
you you know this is the kevin smith
model you max your credit cards or put
two years of your
you know uh finances from your your day
job into making a movie and then to not
see a penny back when somebody else
makes money off of you
it's it's just wrong so you know there's
a little bit of hope not that i want to
become a full-time business manager
distributor but if it
if it worked and we were able to do it i
might be comfortable also assisting some
of my friends and finding a way for them
to get their films out there
i think one of the the greatest skill
sets that i've i've had the chance to do
is
you know canada also has wonderful
grants available to filmmakers that were
part of what we were doing with
the high school shooting movie with four
shots it was a large part of how we got
the scare house financed and made
so i've had a blessing of having mentors
in canadian distributors
uh canadian producers like rob merrilees
out of vancouver who is an executive
producer on four shots
learning the financing system and really
studying and understanding the business
side of film which a lot of filmmakers
don't arm themselves with
i think they do themselves a disservice
of not understanding
the business before they pick up a
camera because
you might make a movie that's unsellable
and that's something you definitely
don't want to do
no matter how good of a movie you made
it might be unsellable because it has to
check
certain boxes will it work in this
country can it sell direct on
on itunes will it will it hit this this
certain market or
if it's the horror market but it's too
funny horror comedies are this weird
space that
don't always hit so i think as much as
most artists don't want to be business
people or understand financing like
uh the best thing you could arm yourself
with is understanding all
aspects of the business as well as the
creative
do you think it's easier to sell a title
in canada do you think canadians are
less
they're more open to looking at topics
whereas the us maybe in the last few
years too has gotten more
is constricted um i think yeah i mean
french canada makes some beautiful films
that
tackle some some big big topics having
that government financing
helps a lot often because then a private
investor
or a distributor or studio doesn't have
to put
as much of the risk capital up because
the the government grants the tax
credits are
are taking a large portion of the
the cash equity that it takes to make a
film so there's a more willingness to
make
you know let's let's call them bolder
films or or less
less common stories because there isn't
as much of a financial risk
but i think as as audiences go i think
we're just just as open as the americans
or anywhere else it's just a matter of
how if those films are made and
available to us we'll watch them
another thing we're fortunate with with
canadian film is the broadcasters the tv
stations and
and whatnot cable stations do you have
to accept a certain amount of canadian
content
as part of their deal to broadcast in
canada so
we're very fortunate that sometimes just
just by default they have to buy
and program canadian content so as a
canadian filmmaker making a canadian
film there are outlets that are
available to you
that favor you over say an american
movie or a british movie or anything
else
in 15 seconds can you describe the
technical premise
behind your latest film last call last
call
is a feature film shot in real time so
single take
no edits but also split screen so
there's two camera crews
shooting simultaneously that when put
together in the edit make up the uh
the entire film and is this a style
you've tried before
i have done uh not split i've done a few
split screen music videos but not real
time
uh i have done a single take 20 minute
short film
and i worked with uh blumhouse
uh the the horror kings to do a a sort
of war the world style
film that was done live on a cell phone
so streamed live
no edits because it was truly live
there's no way to do it again
and that ran about 20 22 minutes it was
a short film that we did right before
halloween a few years ago
and then a bunch of single take music
videos but dealing with
three to five minutes at a time maximum
what other films have you seen
in the style i mean have you seen other
directors do this i mean the one that
everybody knows from back in the day is
rope alfred hitchcock
and although a roll of film can only run
for 10 minutes what they did was they
they hid the edits perfectly so it feels
like a seamless take
uh birdman was shot the same way where
they they hide they hide the edits but
but it keeps that real-time
sort of flavor to it victoria that's on
netflix right now is one of my favorites
from a few years ago
that that one's massive it's over two
hours long it's very complex
moving all over uh german city uh
time code that mike figgis made was
split four ways
and uh done with sort of a loose script
and improv
and it was just fascinating to watch the
experimental films my my favorite so
i've been long obsessed with
making one of these myself it's just
been a matter of finding the right story
that would work
what are some of the hidden challenges
that the audience doesn't see
but from a technical sure from it sorry
technical aspect
our our film we chose to strip down the
crew as much as humanly possible so
traditionally you would have a separate
person pulling focus for the camera
you have a camera assistant for us we
had the camera operator was their own
focus puller
we use the new tilta uh tilt-a-max
with that i forgot the nucleus m but
they're they're handle grips for for a
shoulder mount that have the
the focus wheel in them so they they had
to pull their own focus be their own
assistant there just wasn't room to get
in and out of vehicles
uh move around small apartment spaces up
and down stairs and
uh also try to minimize the amount of
noise the footsteps of it
we really wanted to not have to do any
adr for the actors
adr is when they replace the dialogue it
tends to be always noticeable and never
never
the right emotion we have a very
emotionally heavy film
in that respect our sound guys weren't
able to use
boom mics because again there'd be too
many shadows on walls or catching in the
frame we're trying to
the camera is constantly moving the
actors are constantly moving in and out
of cars elevators it just wouldn't have
been practical so our sound guys were
only able to use
uh like lapel mics lav mics and what we
did was we doubled up the mics we had
two mics on each actor
and that way if one went out we
would hope that the other one was there
if it became untaped and fell down into
their pant leg
hopefully we'd have another option and
we actually recorded them both just
one slightly louder one slightly quieter
just in case somebody screamed
it wouldn't peak but if they were too
quiet if they were whispering we'd have
it on the other mic
so our sound team had the challenge and
then when it comes into post-production
it's the uh
you know when you color correct the film
or want to reframe anything usually if
you're doing it shot by shot
it's easy to just zoom in for that 10
seconds or
color correct shot by shot but in real
time it meant
keyframing which means you know picking
multiple points which by the end of it
we have hundreds if not
thousands of making minor adjustments so
the camera turns
from a doorway into a darker area and we
need to brighten it up a little bit so
that you know sort of all those color
levels and
sound levels are just constantly in flux
throughout the whole movie that aren't
noticeable to the
to the eye but definitely play a huge
part in making the film look
as good as it can and you edit all of
your own films
i do yeah so you added last call this
was my favorite one to edit because i
didn't have to edit anything you know
it really it really truly was two two
takes put side by side so
uh i'm credited as the editor but it
means it means reframing so
if there's a shot where the character of
scott and beth are on the phone and
he's maybe zoomed the cameras closer to
him
i would i would reframe and zoom her
shot in a bit just trying to make
moments where the where the two shots
could be parallel we're just trying to
find the
the best beautiful balance between the
two sides of the story
but also our um although it's split
screen the the split screen changes in
the film
so sometimes it's a horizontal split
screen which we did for sort of the
emotional core of the story the idea is
that that's when they're not
emotionally connected or even actually
connected over the telephone
and then the bar will rotate at times
and go vertical
so that they're that's when they are
connected so the perspective of the film
also changes throughout
so that involved us in post uh you know
adding those rotations in and then also
moving the images at the same time just
to have the best
as it changes from split to find the
best way to present them together
so how is that on the timeline i forgive
me like so you're dragging in both
cameras and and then they're like
layered on top or like how does that
yeah just just uh track one is as beth
side
track to scott's side uh and then
essentially pulling a 50
um uh wipe or or transition over top of
it so that we can only see half
half of the image and then move moving
his side to you know
we what we did when we shot it was we
put line we drew lines on the monitor
so that our uh you know both camera
operators could see
where perfect center was for when it was
a vertical split
so they were actually shooting more on
the left and more on the right so that
we had an ability to
to have some extra room to move but they
also had the lines for the center so
they knew where to put the actors all
the time no matter how they were filming
if it was from this to this
they knew that they could slightly move
and try to just do a very smooth camera
move
it was all handheld and then just put
them between if they were in those
guidelines
it would work out perfect in the edit
and so no
cuts no dissolves nothing just just in
the credits at the end
yeah the movie the movie opens from a
hard black after a
production company logo and then cuts to
a hard black before the credits
so gavin you're directing the movie
there's two screens two locations
there's one gavin how does that work
uh the intention was we would treat it
like a play
once a play starts the director sits in
the audience there's nothing else they
can do all the directing all the prep
all the lighting cue changes and
everything is done
in in the rehearsal process or between
days of performance
uh so i was going to yell action and
wait
the uh 78 90 or 70 80 minutes
and i would not be able to make any
adjustments
for the next take until i watched what
what was shot each day
uh due to some sort of unforeseen
circumstances i ended up camera
operating one of the sides
so as well as directing my camera
our dp seth wessel uh scs
did the one side i did the other side
and
uh which which was helpful because the
take that we use
there are a few minor mistakes the
audience will never know
but it's a moment where you know the
actor could have wanted to cut and i was
at least
able to shout from behind the camera
don't stop fix it keep going
remove that audio and post but so i was
able to make sort of minor adjustments
on on my side of the screen but the
other side i was completely blind to
again shooting a micro budget the ideal
way would be
i'd be sat in a production van somewhere
with
the world's strongest wireless video
feeds coming in so i could monitor
uh both sides but just to do the nature
of our budget and sort of scrappy
approach to making indie film i just had
to sit it out and
hope that it went well until uh until i
could watch it so our process was we
shot it
for four nights so we were going to
shoot twice per night
for four nights and have eight takes
that we would have to
pick one of those eight to be the movie
uh we ended up with five
full takes and a few disasters
oh so you are replaying the scene each
time
like you're not doing new takes in the
the four days or whatever
you're doing you're doing the movie over
again to see which version you like
no no no we would we would film the
entire movie twice per night
for four nights so we we our intention
was to run the entire film
if you think like a stage play if they
had a seven o'clock performance and a
ten o'clock performance
we would do two times per night for four
nights
yeah so eight runs and then choose from
the eight runs yes the best version
right okay
interesting and so your initial plan was
to be it's off
off you know in another location um but
then you became one of the camera
operators
i joked that i was just gonna go have a
whiskey or maybe take a take a sleeping
pill and just wait it out instead of
like nervously pacing for the entire
time
but yeah so i i was not going the camera
off but
uh it became necessary and
with my background and shooting
documentaries and concert footage and
being my own cinematographer for
many many music videos and short films
i didn't think i was going to be able to
do it i thought i was going to give it
one attempt and we'd have to
scrape together some more money and fly
someone in from los angeles
but i did i did the first run everybody
i did i did too good of a job i should
have done a less good job so i didn't
have to
uh so me at the the most out of shape
i've ever been suddenly had to strap
this 50-pound camera on my shoulder and
uh
nail perfect focus for eight takes
and how far are these locations apart we
really lucked out when we were
originally
discussing the film we had the we're
actually going to use a call center
it wasn't going to be a college and it
wasn't going to be a suicide hotline
it's going to be like a telemarketing
center that
the character beth was a janitor at and
that was a good
seven to eight miles away from where
where the apartment in the bar location
was
but then when the college came aboard
saint claire college in windsor
the locations are actually only about
two city blocks from from each other
so uh anytime she's outside of the
college
if the camera pointed up you could see
the 17-story apartment building that
he's in
like if you've been on the balcony at
the same time she was outside you may
have even
seen him in the distance with a trained
eye so that made production a little
easier because at the end of every take
or during rehearsal it was only a block
or so to go we had to
drive eight miles every time we had to
do something or deliver a new battery or
or meet for a lunch break it would have
added it would have sort of just
extrapolated the amount of time that we
needed
we probably would have had to find money
and have more days of rehearsal and
and more time so we were very you know
it's just honestly this project came
together
with so little production trouble we're
considering the
the task we were trying to accomplish um
everything just started to fall into
places like that so we knew that windsor
was the right choice to film in
we picked the right crew and the right
people to make it happen because the
even though the process of making the
film was not easy the elements that
normally cause production so many so
many problems
in terms of finding perfect locations
and and space and then
for the right price and all the other
aspects of it
fell fell in line fairly easy
are you sharing monitor from one
location's footage with the other
location or no because you're doing
these long takes
when you get back then you reassess it
yeah completely blind
uh not until we what we would do is we
we shot all of our rehearsals
we had 10 days of rehearsal which was
performance rehearsal
active rehearsal the first three days
four days we were not
in the same location like what we would
do is we would have both sarah and david
the actors
in the apartment and david's or scott's
apartment so she would just sit in
another room in the apartment
and read lines over the phone it was
just easier to give notes and make
changes
and then eventually we got comfortable
with splitting into the two locations
and once we were there
we would record every rehearsal and just
instead of recording we shot the movie
at 8k
on the red the red helium but we decided
we shot it with the rehearsals of 1080p
because it was just easy at the end of
every night to put all of the rehearsal
takes
into a computer and just just roughly
frame the the
split so everybody watched the
rehearsals day in and day out
like or i guess every night and you know
our dp could say ah that that light's a
little too bright i should change this
let's try to make the cameras line up
here better when we get to this moment
when they're talking and
so we sort of use it like like the way
uh i would say like the way a coach
would use a game tape from a football
game to analyze
mistakes or things they could approve or
or titan performance or maybe a band you
know if they watch back their own
concert what did you say
ah it looks silly when you do that or
that pyrotechnic didn't go off let's
make sure we fix that
uh sort of treated like again all i
needed was the uh the thing to draw on
the screen you know to circle
circle players and it would have been a
true game tape
how are you dealing with lighting
especially if you're moving and if
you're having people you know physically
one thing so as well as the camera
operators having to be their own focus
pullers
they also had an iris control so they're
moving say from the
the street was a little brighter than
the bar they've got to close the iris
but do it do it
at a speed of very gentle speed so that
we don't really notice it some of that
we
just tweak in post production and color
to correct
um everything out on the streets is just
available light whenever street light
was there
the bar was mostly practical but
augmented with some film light
so we would have to install everything
hide all the cables because
you know we are filming every location
360 degrees
so there's nowhere to hide a stand or
leave a cable visible
the college the overhead lights are
practical but we did wrap them in a
different color gel just to give a bit
moodier
moodier tone than just sort of the hot
white that you get from fluorescence
everything else in the college is quasar
tubes which have become super popular
kind of look like led tubes you can
change the color on them you see them
in movies all the time now because you
can set them up as a practical lamp
they look great as like under lights in
a kitchen counter or on the wall of an
office or anything kind of sci-fi
they're great so we use those in the
computer lab where we use small quasars
to
accent so say like an exit sign in a
classroom that she's cleaning just to
give it a bit more red and make it a bit
more ominous
uh and then the apartment that scott's
in
it's mostly practical it's changing a 60
watt bulb to 100 watt bulb
like putting a light in the fridge when
if he's going to open it that there's a
little different a light over the stove
there were a few lights out on the on
the balcony
uh when he's out there that are that are
hidden that aren't that are film lights
but
the majority of that set was just done
all
practical so there may be a filmmaker
watching right now
who's inspired by the film or the idea
what advice would you give them what are
some of the biggest pitfalls to making a
film in this style
ample rehearsal time if you're going to
make something in real time it really
all comes down to the planning i mean
all film is pre-production
to make it go well i just think you have
to a lot more time before
you roll roll camera in order to make
sure that every little detail is right
it is a
it's like learning dance choreography
for the camera operators and
the technical crew uh and and the actors
to a sense there's just so much to
remember where you can't say oh i messed
that up let's just go back to ones and
start again the more times you do that
if you're 40 minutes into a 70 minute
take and you have to start over
it's it's costs a lot of money and a lot
of time to continue to do that so you
really want to
put as much prep into it as humanly
possible i think the other thing to
consider too is even in like a
four-minute single take music video
we've had moments where like
uh it's kind of boring for 20 seconds
you know you have to find a way that
if you're gonna do a film with no edits
how do you keep it interesting like
what's the story
it can't just be a gimmick it can't just
be we did it in a single take
because the first question is why you
have to justify why you're using that
format and that goes the same for any
any style of filmmaking
why are you using handheld why are you
doing everything on a steadicam like
you have to you have to know why you're
doing things what the camera motivation
is
what story do you possibly have to tell
that doesn't require cuts or
keeps that immediacy and that that sort
of that that was our our goal to
make a film that would always feel
immediate always feel tension
if that phone call ends this man's life
might end
so putting that tension we thought the
easiest because every time you cut or
have a fade in the fade out to later
you get attention relief so you probably
want to be telling a story that
you know undeniably cannot break the
tension in order to tell
something in real time and then study
study the masters go watch time code go
watch victoria you know
make sure you really consider even even
our cinematographer seth
you know he's an established
cinematographer the first thing he did
was reach out to the the dp
of victoria and just said how
how did you do this how did you do that
and he wrote back he was very kind he
said i don't i don't have time to answer
every individual question
i get asked this a lot but i put
together this faq that sort of like runs
the gamut of questions you could
probably ask
if there's not if there's anything after
that you know please
please reach out so yeah ask people who
have been there before
because most people are excited to share
their knowledge in this industry
uh especially if it's something that's
in a rare format or rare style
uh you know i can say positively the
people that gave me help and advice on
how to do it i'd be more than happy to
to pass that on so that's it do your
research
figure out why you want to tell the
story that way don't make it just a
gimmick um
you know have have something real to say
was it the last version of shooting like
the last day
that ended up making it in the film or
no it was
day three of four the first take so we
shot this this first take
that night and everybody felt amazing
about it we knew there were two little
mistakes in it but we knew that we could
like
work the mistakes into the story we
found it was basically two times that
scott tries to use the phone to call but
actually misdialed
and got a wrong number so he just had to
hang up the phone we're like well we'll
just
we'll add in like you've reached so and
so mechanics we're not open until the
morning
so we can fix that if everything else
but everybody felt so positive about it
we said instead of
exhausting ourselves going again tonight
let's let's stop let's all go home we're
exhausted at this point through
rehearsal and
said the camera guys get a break
everyone gets a break let's just come
back tomorrow and try to like go for
broke and do one bigger and better
knowing that we can live with this being
the take so the next day on the fourth
day
we did uh our last take which was our
fifth take overall
uh we got one and it was really good but
ultimately we
we did come back to the one that we all
knew in our guts would uh would be the
take
and that was the very first one it was
the no it was the first take of day
three take four or five yeah wow
what was the emotion like when even
though you did one last take you went
home rested
but knowing that this could this one
looked really good even though there
were two little minor things
how was that pure relief you know we're
getting we're on our second last day
where it's like the money runs out
tomorrow
we can't come back we lose some of our
crew flights are booked for people to
fly back to los angeles like
it's do or die and uh it there
there definitely was a sense of i don't
know if we're going to get this
we always knew that going in that you
know it's experimental
this might not work out we had to tell
our
investors you know we this might not
happen you know so that's part of what
you have to understand in investing in
an experimental film
we might have to do some cuts in there
to mix tapes together and just you know
not make a real-time movie anymore but
when we got it it was uh
it was interesting because sometimes it
came down to like the can the technical
would be perfect
but one of the two actors would be like
i wasn't i know i just know it wasn't my
best take
but the other actor would have had an
amazing take but then you have you have
this unbalance
of characters that wouldn't work and
just something with that take when we
were finished
everybody knew it was it was great so it
was
a lot of celebrating but also
nervousness because like okay well
we got to come back tomorrow and try to
like we know there's things that don't
work here it's got to be it's got to be
perfect but it's it's relief
and i felt that many times doing single
take music videos generally on indie
music videos or any music videos now you
get
one day so if you're doing single take
you you don't often have a day of
rehearsal even budget wise you show up
that day
you've got 12 hours to build it prep it
design it shoot it and have it done
so you usually get to around hour 10
hour 11
being like why why do i keep doing these
single tape things like just
to be so much easier if we cut so i
think like anything when it comes down
to like
it's it's like the winning point i'm
terrible sports analogies but it's like
if you've only got so much time on the
shot clock to get that final
you know that final goal or the final
couple points to win the game
it really comes down to that pressure
like if you're that if you're that
kicker in the super bowl that's gonna
make or break
the super bowl rings you uh you the
minute you kick that goal
through that is nothing but relief
so then you really didn't have a rough
cut once you finish sort of piecing
together different parts
it was basically just a few things and
it was done
yeah it was uh i mean the reframing took
a while the color grading took a while
but
yeah they put a rough cut together it
was like same same day essentially like
tape
temp some some music in and again our
audio tracks it's just
one audio or two audio tracks from each
microphone so four audio tracks but it's
all
one long continuous real time so to sync
those up was was nothing so there's
immediately a rough cut we got accepted
to our first film festival off of a
rough cut before our composer had done
the music
because it he you know although he
scored the movie live
um like recorded in life he took the
time to write it and we talked about
where the music would go and get all the
sheet music prep for the musicians and
whatnot
uh but yeah it was it was very
interesting to like walk away from a
movie not then have that like
the next few months of my life for
sitting in this dark room
staring endlessly at these four second
30 second clips trying to put a movie
together
do you think you'll ever make a film in
this style again i have plans to do
something bigger
bigger and more challenging than this i
i don't know why it's like a blessing
and a curse to be obsessed with this
this idea in this format um something
about it that's
when everything can go wrong that's the
most exciting thing i think for me
it's like it's the only way i don't ride
i don't drive motorcycles
you know i don't rock climb so this is
this is my adrenaline rush of uh
how can we how can we make things more
experimental
and and put more risk because i think
when the payoff is there at the end
it's it's it's well worth it and i just
the more
even even when i shoot traditional
movies i'm like well can't we just do
this whole scene in a single take like
that's been happening a lot and
my short films have gone from 10 minutes
to 17 minutes because i'm like well i
got these three scenes that we
we can't cut because they're single take
i don't even know i should probably ask
myself seriously what what about it is
that i love
maybe i should have been a theater
director well you said you thrive on
chaos
i mean that's something some people are
their best yeah like some people are
great
emergency room doctors or you know
whatever they they thrive in that
and that thankfully i don't have to save
anyone's life but if i did
i could probably do it on the first yeah
in one take
so you enjoy that the adrenaline rush
all of that yeah whenever there's even
traditional movies when it's you know uh
there's gonna be fire or a stunt or
something where everything's just gotta
like work in perfect harmony with each
other
that's always the most exciting stuff
like don't get me wrong i love directing
a dinner table scene between two people
falling in love but that's
it's uh it's just not as exciting as all
the
all the big stuff and the fun stuff so
when you sort of take those regular
dramatic moments and put them in this
real-time element there's just a lot
more
a lot more chaos not dinner with andre
yeah yeah in a single thing
how old were you when you made your
first feature film i was
23 years old i had watched
kevin smith in high school a little
maybe 22.
i watched kevin smith rodriguez you know
richard linklater all these guys come up
like i made my film between 7 000 and 25
000 i just maxed my credit card sold my
comic book sold my car and then i went
put it in sundance and signed a million
dollar deal with miramax and like oh
that's all that's all it takes
i can come up with 25 000 and then fail
miserably
because what they leave out of all those
glossy stories is you have to make an
amazing movie
and making an amazing movie for no money
when you have no idea what you're doing
is
next to impossible so the people who've
done it are in some very rarefied air
and they're they're where they are
because they had that raw talent and raw
ability right out of the gate
but what that gave me that i always say
failure is the best teacher
and that was you know we made a movie
that was passable and i enjoy it i'm
still very proud of it but
we had no idea how to sell it we didn't
get into sundance
what do you do then that was your one
and only goal uh
being a kid from canada you know living
living in the dark ages of like
limited internet and we didn't have
facebook and social media and film
freeway and all these wonderful things
to know about
a lot of these film festivals that exist
today didn't exist then like we had no
idea
what we were doing so it was a lack of
education and how the business works
a lack of understanding that just
because you made a movie
that has nothing to do with if people
will ever see it or buy it
or or even know it exists
so yeah it was it was a movie that uh it
taught me the basics of how to make a
movie
uh it was creative it was fun uh it
excited me enough to go make another one
but it was uh it was a complete disaster
in terms of actually
ever getting to market or making
something that was uh
of quality enough for people to to
embrace
what was it about it's what three
it's called leaving town there's about
three uh young people
like just sort of post post high school
into college where life's just not
working out
for for three very different reasons
that all end up
uh just serendipitously running into a
bar in their hometown
and uh one of them's got a much darker
secret that he hasn't told the other two
and he proposes well we should
rob the local bank and leave town
forever
um which they do and then one thing
after another continues to not work out
and the irony of the title is
they may or may not even get out of town
by the end of it and was
was it worth it to ultimately ruin their
lives
way worse than they they started with so
what did
your perceived failure of it whether it
was a failure or not
what did that teach you uh it taught me
that i was going to have to learn a lot
more about the business and
how distribution works and like you know
we were shooting on the
the amazing camera at the time of the
dvx 100
um you know that was the first camera
that came out that shot 24 frames a
second
it mimicked film had a beautiful look to
it but it was still
pretty independent it wasn't 16
millimeter film it wasn't 35
involved a lot more post work than we
really knew what we were doing to
to achieve uh a quality look with it
but it was mostly the business end of
things just not knowing living in
windsor ontario canada and not knowing a
single person of
how to also had a very depressing moment
where
uh we had lightning it was we think it
was a lightning strike or a power surge
but something in our office
fried the computer and fried the hard
drive and the backup copy had been uh
record like not record over but like
copied over with wedding footage that uh
somebody at the company had like filmed
a family wedding with so we didn't have
the backup suddenly
so the film had to be re-edited from
from scratch
which was a major major setback and that
set us back a good
year year and a half because then we
could only edit it in
our spare time and got it finished again
and i think just a lot of people like
just
the love and the excitement was gone and
that's that's that's a hard lesson to
learn that like you know if you're gonna
commit to doing independent film it's
years of your life you've got to be
there to the bitter end till every last
possible
interview sale you know screening
spending more money on film festivals
that was part of it too we've raised
enough money to make
the movie to shoot it but then you don't
realize how expensive proper post is and
we hadn't researched that or
what it's going to take to transfer to
film to send to festivals at the time
or even get the cost of submitting the
film festivals or traveling to them was
all things that were
beyond our comprehension and ultimately
was oh well
you can't really make a movie for 25 000
you can get it done but you can't
there's a lot more to it that uh
is necessary to get it out there did you
edit it
i did yeah okay even though i collected
it with a that one i co-wrote
co-directed and co-edited so
i only had 50 percent of the the
heartache from that one
besides this interview what else are you
doing for your filmmaking career today
if you could just take us through a
rundown i have a hard drive full of six
short films experimental shorts that i
just shot when we had free time or
access to free gear that i have to sit
down and edit
and start getting out there we have
another feature in october that we're
prepping to
to go to camera with another weird
experimental movie
uh last call is on the festival circuit
we've
sort of been having some amazing
response and some people reaching out
saying they want to help us to sell it
so that's been
exciting to see what could happen uh and
then
my you know quote unquote day job is
music videos so there's a few things on
the pipeline coming up
always sort of one in the edit while
another one's being prepped and
that's uh that should see out 2019 yeah
what makes a great story a great story
is great characters great premise
and earn what they call earned moments
which is you can't just have this happen
to a character so that this can happen
in the plot
everything has to be earned um people
talk about
in the last this last season of game of
thrones a lot of people that didn't
enjoy it
didn't feel it was earned it's just oh
the queen went mad
and now she's mad and angry they did
they didn't feel earned
from uh from a show that otherwise for
years had
very slowly developed things that you
know like
had her madness set in over a season or
two it would have been a different thing
so i think it's really about just
understanding that although you could
have an amazing plot you could have the
next purge you could have the next blair
witch project like
the characters living through the events
of that movie have to be strong and feel
real
and and these sort of emotional
victories that they have
or the things that set them back
emotionally or physically
all have to be earned moments they all
have to be things that feel
believable versus just oh they did that
so they can get from a
to b it has to be something that
organically fits the story and the
characters
have you seen a lot of indie films use
sort of non-earned
conflict so they know they have to have
conflict right away but
the audience isn't buying why there's
the conflict see yeah see it all the
times just fight you know
fight starts between two actors because
it's the moment where a fight has to
start or
you know just seems to be triggered by
the trigger point of of that argument or
conflict
or or just simply um i won't name the
screenwriting book but there's you know
there's one that everybody has attracted
to everybody's
films start to feel exactly the same
because they're they're relying on this
this beat system of when the beats have
to be hit
versus like how to best get from beat a
to b b to beat c
how do you know the protagonist is
someone you want to write about
i think you usually identify a little
bit with your protagonist if you're
writing your original story
so you're writing from a place sometimes
where you understand if you don't have
exactly the same life situations or even
conflict in the story you're always
putting a little bit of yourself into
these characters
and you should only write they say write
what you know um
i feel a good protagonist is somebody
that you either want to be like
or don't want to be like the two extreme
ends of it i think that's what makes
anybody who's severely flawed or just
um severely wonderful you know i think
those those are where i start with most
things of how do i
you know i do write a lot of plot-driven
things so like the plot
comes first but
nothing works if you don't have a
protagonist that you really care about
or care why the
plot elements are happening to him or
her so i think i'm trying to think
that's a very good question but you just
you have to
want to see them succeed it has to be a
character that's that's likable even if
they're flawed
you know walter white and breaking bad
even even the
redemption of darth vader there has to
be something in them even if they're
like an evil character that you
you want them to succeed or
find that redemption or earn back the
trust of the other characters in the
story well can you give me example of a
character that's severely wonderful
i mean we know so many that are very
flawed yeah i mean
uh andy dufreyne and shawshank
redemption
you know even though he's in the worst
situation
rarely does he let that change his
optimism
change his willingness to to help the
people around him with like positioning
to start a library
or teaching people to get their ged
while he's in prison and going through
these horrific
scenarios you know and never never sort
of letting the system
system get to him that's a good example
in under five minutes can you give us
the best screenwriting advice
be be different don't just because
you've read a book on screenwriting
don't follow that exact format
read screenplays read every screenplay
you can
from amateur to professional
look movies you've watched get those
screenplays
especially sites like i don't even know
if it still exists but like drew
scriptarama or anywhere that houses
screenplays or
especially if you live in la there's
stores sell them
try to get early drafts of scripts and
understand the changes that they made to
production
i think the more you read and see the
evolution of how
how writing is changing over the years
how character development
and dialogue and just all the different
i think it's about
looking at all the different because you
know there isn't one set
format for writing a screenplay there
used to be it's not so much anymore but
i think the more you
you read you just filter through this
works for what i'm doing
this doesn't work but you just see the
way that people use description
um it's just practice and for indie
filmmakers don't shoot your first draft
your first draft is not perfect i mean
unless you're
the next you know robert robert town or
you know somebody somebody who's got
just this amazing ability to
kevin smith with clerks even but i bet
you that wasn't his first draft like
just because you finished it and it was
really difficult doesn't mean it's
perfect
so get feedback stage table reads
listen to the advice that people give
you even if you don't like it you're
always going to fight for some things
you don't have to take everyone's advice
you will never not learn something you
didn't think of
or didn't see as being a problem in your
script the more people you asked
to give their feedback and their input
now of course sometimes you want to do
something weird and wild that
people won't understand and that's okay
you don't have to change it
but you have to rewrite and rewrite and
rewrite
get that feedback because it's so
important to shape there's no way that
any one writer can have all the answers
and
and bang out a perfect screenplay
without that guidance and help
did you ever think what your life would
be like if you hadn't gone to that third
eye blind concert
probably shooting wedding videos in
windsor ontario
yeah i'm not i'm not sure what would be
it would be dif i think i've got
i've got the fight in me i've wanted to
make movies for a long time it would
have figured
figured out a way could be it's
nothing you can't think about right you
know because the uh the the sliding
doors affect that gwen
paltrow movie or the butterfly ripple um
[Music]
if i got a more traditional way would i
be making the experimental movies i'm
making now
maybe not maybe i'd have more success
working in the studio system or for
television networks
uh but it would be wildly different
because that also just taught me to
start sneaking into everything
as long as i wasn't breaking the law you
know i met my wife sneaking into a party
at the toronto film festival
um definitely wouldn't have done that
had it not worked previously so
successful with bands and
i've used it to sneak into events where
i know i could
meet people that could potentially read
scripts or take a meeting with
say it would be wildly different
what would you tell a 20 year old
filmmaker on the realities of making a
living as a filmmaker
it's funny because i just started a
podcast with the same idea which is
the phrase here's my advice not that
you'll take it
listen to the people giving you advice
first talk because you think
that they're coming from what they're
going to tell you if it's honest advice
is
harsh it's not going to be easy it's
going to require a lot more money
and patience and heartache than you
think you can bear
and you're going to say they just sound
jaded because they've been around a long
time there must be a faster
cheaper easier way to get this done and
then you'll fumble in the dark for a
long time to eventually turn around and
say
oh that advice they gave me i should
have taken it so
listen to your elders you know you hit a
certain point where you start saying
that to people and say oh that's exactly
what my parents said to me
but yeah the best thing is just
take take advice take the time to learn
don't ever think that you're above
something like if you want to be a
director
great go grip on some people's films and
understand
and watch other directors work
understand how important every role in
that set is
so that you never talk down or take it
and take anyone for granted that's on
the set
and just keep making stuff like even if
you're
even if you're not proud of the short
you made put it up online anyways
it's part of learning to take criticism
it's part of learning to fail
um yeah just keep making stuff and
understand that
it's it's uh it's the longest
relationship you'll you'll ever have
um because you will fall in and out of
love with it along the way
but it doesn't mean you should ever give
up or not give it a second chance or not
find a way to
uh you know make amends kiss and make up
with
yourself and your creative dreams um and
don't ever think that a major setback
means it's over
because you're gonna have a lot of them
and most of us do not all of us are
lucky to get plucked out of film school
with our first film and
and have a star track record right to
their uh you know a lifetime achievement
awards
at the end of their career it's it's a
it's a lot of a lot of misery it's uh
like i always say it's 99 setbacks for
every one thing that works out
so when that hunter thing works out it
has to fill you with so much
excitement and joy and courage
and wanting to like go and make the next
thing that the next that
it will it will shield you from the next
99 disappointments
so then when you get the next one you
gotta do the same thing so
that's that's the reality of it it's
gonna it's gonna sting for a long time
but you gotta just enjoy what you're
doing along the way
and learn to not be end career focused
because you never know how it's
gonna come about but if you try to
fixate on it has to be this this and
this
rarely life is that so you have to be
able to say it's going to be this
but i might have to take this sideways
trip it looked like one of those indiana
jones maps at the beginning or you know
james bond
they're going from country to country
they want to go from here to here
sometimes that means solids got to take
them all over here to get back to that
arc
what's the biggest obstacle right now
that you're facing in your career
uh getting
something like last call that we've made
and we believe in we've had
good small critical response uh you know
a couple festival audiences that have
been raving about it on social media
telling everyone to watch it
just how to get that in front of people
you know because everybody's trying to
get their work in front of people so
what do you do to stand out
how do you use a manager and an agent to
the full potential of like making sure
that people
are gonna when they get 100 emails a day
saying watch the screen or watch the
screener
what can you do to make yours stand out
uh i think that's that's the biggest
thing like you know because they're
they're always going to be
powers above that have to green light
things or or open up the
financial purse so that you get to make
your next project
uh and i've i've always sort of
struggled with that where you know i've
had a lot of people
say to me you should be much further in
your career than you than you are
man we can't believe that you're still
struggling but you've got all these
great ideas like
that's just the reality of it you know
you have to you have to
wake up every day and want to do this
and know that it's also a lottery you
know there's a lot of great
singer-songwriters that i know that i
think are
far more talented than half the rsi
let's do on the radio
people don't know who they are and part
of this industry really is luck and
timing
and you don't you can make your own luck
to a degree
but you have no control over the destiny
of timing of when things will align for
you so
um yeah that's that's the biggest
challenge has been just how to get
the work out there but the great uh
remedy to that is to just keep making
work and you know they what's the
the phrase to be so great they can't
ignore you you know just keep making
content
keep keep chipping away at that career
and you know hopefully
the larger opportunities present
themselves would you really say the
perception is that you're struggling
because you have such a large body of
work
and it's excellent but in order to do
that it's come
at the at the sacrifice of like having a
much more lucrative day job
or having the financial stability and
you know moving from canada to america
comes with a lot of
like financial strain and things that uh
that are not are not
easy um working between the two
countries that adds a lot of like time
away
in terms of like relationships and
family and
um yeah i definitely would say i'm i
mean
it's also what they classify as like
first world problems
you know like there's there's a lot
greater stripes in the world that people
people struggle with
uh but it's that it's it's just not
letting the mindset of uh
of defeat case it's like not it's like
getting to
go for your super bowl winning game and
ring like 17 times in a row but never
winning
somewhere in you you've got a question
saying am i a good enough athlete and am
i surrounding myself with the best
athletes i can
in order to do this and you can't ever
let that trick you and say
no you have to say no we're the right
team
we're the right athletes it's just not
our game yet it just means that
it doesn't matter how good we are there
was somebody a little bit better than us
you know you've seen that in the history
of
let's use i mean the oscars are an easy
example for filmmakers
you see people that like how many times
did roger deacons lose
best cinematography even though he's
considered one of the greatest of all
time
but if you look year to year and are
honest and say i can't believe you
didn't win for
this movie and then you go oh that's the
film that won that film was amazing you
know like
there's always there's always something
so it doesn't matter how great you are
how do you how do you edge out or or get
past
um you know it's it's the most one of
the most competitive industries in the
world so
you have to you have to know that you're
searching for a very very rare prize at
the end of it
are you competitive or you just want to
make great great like sort of like tell
great stories
i i i both in me i have bouts of being
being competitive and trying to you know
i'm
i'm very good to energize myself and be
strategic to get myself and i'm
definitely not afraid to get in front of
people
and use whatever um you know connections
or favors that i can possibly ask to
make that happen
but at the same time uh i also just
want to make great stuff i think that's
probably part of the struggle is uh
i'm not selling i was not the right term
but i'm not
i'm not as willing to sort of monetize
like i'd probably make
an excellent mentor or like script
writing coach or something to people
that i could actually charge
money for but i i do have that and not
to like
i don't have an ascot on that i can wave
and put my sunglasses on i'm not trying
to be artsy fartsy but like
the artist part of me just wants to make
and create things and that's that's more
important than figuring out how to
monetize it
why is it important for you to be a
filmmaker and not a film watcher
oh man i
i think i mean it starts with my dad
he's a photographer
we always had sort of like eight
millimeter cameras kicking around the
house so
from a very early age i was playing with
like stop motions making stop-motion
lego things uh i wanted and i wanted to
be a writer first that's that's the real
truth i wanted to write novels and then
when i kind of got obsessed with writing
movies
but again when i was 18 or 20 i'm
writing these movie scripts i i didn't
know that i should move to l.a and get
an agent i didn't know any of this
i thought well i need to get one of
these made so that people can see what
my words look like on the screen
and there was no facebook there was no i
needed producer groups there was no uh
in it cool news chat rooms where you
could meet you know you could meet other
people
and i just i said okay well i don't know
any directors i guess i'll just direct
it
i don't know any other cinematographers
i guess i'll pick up a camera and learn
how to shoot things
but as i sort of started exploring each
of those elements i realized oh these
are all
very related and and i like i like them
i loved editing i was always editing
videos in high school so i've always
sort of been just
uh afflicted with wanting to tell
stories in one form or another
and then i realized that when i paired
the right visuals and the right dialogue
with the right music that i had a
really good ability to sort of draw
emotion out of people and sort of get
the
not be manipulative but if i wanted
people to cry i could i could make that
happen with like telling a sad tale if i
wanted people to laugh
i knew how to time the edits and and the
jokes and things to work and i just
it's like uh i don't use drugs
which i know if i did i'd be just as
addicted to them as filmmaking so
filmmaking is like like my drug i just
have to wake up every day
never i never stop thinking of stories i
can be in
i can go to trader joe's after this on
the way home and something
something will happen i'll see something
i'll look down at the wheel of the cart
wobbling and be like
that would be a great shot and then the
setup would be this and this character
knows this character because it's just
it's just always sort of churning so i
can't imagine doing anything else
i've tried to quit a couple times and
just go do do a different job but it's
always it's always come back mostly my
friends saying
what else are you gonna do you can't
you're you're programmed to do this
so you wanted to be a novel like william
gibson or just
yeah i just it started writing uh hey
pixar if you're listening i have this
pitch since third grade
uh in third grade we had to do a thing
called write a one-page story called
my life is an easter egg and the premise
was everybody got the same piece of
paper
the teacher had written at the top my
life is an easter egg dot dot dot
you had to write a one page story so i
ended up turning in like this 38 or 39
page story that started with
i was a chocolate easter egg that was
manufactured in this plant
and then it's i remember like the the um
it's like the cvs of canada shoppers
drug mart or
you could get your your name like your
kids name written on the easter egg so
it'd be customized when they got this
chocolate egg
just done with frosting and so my idea
was i was
like my easter egg was a personalized
egg and it was going to this little kid
jimmy
in saskatchewan and that meant he had to
get on a truck but then the truck ended
up taking a wrong exit
and like people robbed the truck and the
egg ended up like going so it was all
about this easter eggs almost like a toy
story of a chocolate easter egg of like
the misadventures of him just like no i
have to get to this kid i have to
there's this 30 and then like my third
grade teacher just looked at my parents
like uh
i think you might be a writer you know i
think that imagination might be
hyperactive
how cool that's a great story did it get
to jimmy
uh it did it did and now pixar you could
make this your next franchise